[Musique]
en Haïti le président rtide a
démissionné ce matin il a quitté le pays
pour une destination incertaine on parle
d'antigois dans l'île scène de violence
et de pillage Port au Prince est aux
mains de bandes armées Washington
annonce l'arrivée de marines dans les
heures qui viennent déjà des troupes
canadiennes auraient pris le contrôle de
l'aéroport la frontière entre la France
et l'Espagne est à nouveau accessible au
poids lourd depuis plus de 48 he des
milliers de camions sont bloqués le
ravitaillement s'est organisé tant bien
que mal un weekend de galère pour les
camionneurs le procès de marque du trou
s'ouvrira demain en Belgique dans la
petite ville d'arl où sont arrivés des
médias du monde entier 8 ans après les
faet d'innombrabl dysfonctionnement dans
l'enquête ce procès un retentissement
très profond dans le
pays la lutte contre l'insécurité
routière avec dès demain l'apparition
d'un permis de conduire à destination
des jeunes conducteurs qui les mettra à
l'épreuve pendant une période de 3 ans
le permis n'est plus acquis à vie ça
nous aura pas échappé nous sommes le 29
février une drôle de date anniversaire
pour tous ceux qui sont nés ce jour-là
voilà Monsieur bonsoir en Haïti sous la
pression le président arestide a
finalement démissionné à l'aube depuis
la confirmation officielle de son départ
le pays est livré à lui-même Haïti est
aux mains de bandes armées hors de tout
contrôle d'un côté une apparence de
l'égalité avec désormais comme le veut
la Constitution le pouvoir qui revient
au président de la suprême de l'autre
des violences qui ont éclaté dans le
centre de port auprce où les milices de
l'ancien président ne semblent pas décid
à laisser la place dans ce climat
d'anarchie Washington vient de décider
l'envoi dès aujourd'hui de troupes
américaines qui dans un deuxième temps
pourrait être intégré à une force
internationale Florence bouquillya
Bertrand coq Gill jaquier c'est fini
pour arestide tôt ce matin il quitte
Haïti cédant à la fois à la pression des
rebelles et à celle de la France puis
des États-Unis destination encore
inconnue peut-être
P la capit le Premier
ministre le
départ que c'est pour éviter unain de
sang
qu'il a accepté de
démissionner avant la fin de son
mandat comme le prévoit la Constitution
Boniface Alexandre jusque là président
de la Cour de cassation devient donc
président d'Haïti par intérim dans les
rues de la capitale c'est le
chaos tout le monde ou presque est
armé les partisans d'Ar chim contrôlent
encore la ville et il la son à bord de
leur pickup il participent aussi au
pillage magasin habitation et même
commissariat tout et tous devienent C
pour gu Philipp le chef militaire des
insurgés le départ de jeanbertrand
Aristide est un véritable cadeau
d'anniversaire pour lui qui fête
aujourd'hui ses 36 ans il y a des
problèmes dans la capitale alors nous y
allons pour rendre la sécurité aux gens
ramener la sécurité le nouveau Paris des
rebelles qui avait accédé à la demande
des Américains d'attendre le départ de
Jean-Bertrand Aristide avant d'entrer
dans Port auprce en direct de port
auprce nous vous retrouvons Bertrand coq
alors Debord peut-être un point de la
situation à l'heure qu'il est y a-t-il
encore des des scènes de violence et de
pillage la ville est fermée sur
elle-même
oui Béatrice d'abord vous confirmez
l'information que vous donnez Florence
bouquilla les rebelles du Nord sont bien
entr en ville je les ai vu il y a moins
d'une demi-heure ils sont pour l'instant
dans le dans les haut de Port au Prince
sont des hommes calmes bien équipés
manifestement disciplinés ils ne sont
que quelques-uns mais ils ont annoncé
leur intention de descendre dans le bas
de la ville organiser des patrouilles
essayer d'y ramener le calme car
effectivement le bas de porort auprce
est toujours livré au pillage les
supermarchés toutes les boutiques sont
vidées tel que je vois les choses les
chimères les les milices du président
ont pris acte de ce que aristide était
parti mais se servent avant d'aller se
terer dans le bidonville revenons si
vous voulez bien sur le le fil des
événements comment s'est déroulé cette
démission qui semblait au fond
inévitable
oui rapidement Béatrice ça s'est passé
ce matin très tôt Jean-Bertrand Aristide
a signé sa démission chez lui vers 6h du
matin et puis il est parti il a quitté
le pays en avion ensuite l'action s'est
déplacée au siège du gouvernement
monsieur Neptune qui est le le Premier
ministre de Jean-Bertrand Aristide a
annoncé officiellement le départ du
président et puis le président de la
cour de C a été nommé président par
intérim monsieur Neptune va rester en
fonction encore pendant quelques heures
le temps que Monsieur Boniface le
nouveau président désigne un nouveau
Premier ministre et forme un autre
gouvernement et tout cela s'est déroulé
je tiens à vous le dire en présence de
l'ambassadeur de France et de celui des
États-Unis avez-vous pour finir quelques
informations concernant la dtination de
l'ex-président aristi contrairement aux
premières informations son avion
n'aurait pas atterri en République
Dominicaine vous pouvez nous le
confirmer c'est ce qu'on dit on dit
qu'il est pas en République Dominicaine
on le dit à Antigua une île des Caraïbes
mais surtout en train de se chercher un
pays d'accueil il semblerait que ni le
Maroc ni l'Afrique du Sud n n'est voulu
de lui merci Bertrand coq les insurgés
se disent donc prêt vous l'avez dit ce
soir à déposer les armes et attendent
l'arrivée au plus vite d'une force
internationale pour l'instant seul les
troupes américaines feraient route vers
Haïti en France aucune décision n'a
encore été arrêtée la communauté
internationale qui avait beaucoup peu
vré en coulisse ces derniers jours pour
sortir le pays de la crise pourrait
ajuster le plan de règlement refusé
jusquors par le présidenttide Paul de
Genève 500 marines supplémentaires
débarqueront dans les heures qui
viennent en Haïti la réaction des
États-Unis ne s'est donc pas fa attendre
les Américains veulent agir vite ils
craignent que le pays ne sombre dans le
chaos et que le flot des réfugiés ne
devienne incontrôlable des centaines
d'entre eux ont déjà été refoulés par
les gardescôtes ces 500 soldatsirai tout
d'abord pour le compte des intérêts
américains dans un premier temps
seulement selon George
Bush
j'ai donné l'ordre de déployer un
contingent de Marines ce sera l'élément
majeur d'une force internationale chargé
de ramener l'ordre et la paix en
Haïti de son côté l'Élysée qui a déjà
envoyé hier cet avion militaire a fait
savoir que la France était disposée à
déployer une force de paix proposition
déjà évoquée ce matin par Dominique de
Villepin en déplacement au Japon il faut
maintenant que les combats cessent la
France appelle toutes les forces
politiques d'Haïti à se rassembler et à
participer à la réconciliation nationale
la France est prête à prendre toute sa
part dans la mobilisation de la
communautéégale et internationale il
faut sansetard MRE en l'aide humanitaire
d'urgence les États-Unis ont réamé leote
d'une résolution du conse de sécurité
des Nations unies sur un soutien
internation en Haïti ce soir les troupes
canadiennes ont sécurisé l'aéroport en
attendant le déploi américain
ancien prêtre porte-parole des S voies
des plus petits Jean-Bertrand aristite
faisait figure de libérateur dans les
années 90 après avoir été donc deux fois
contraint d'abandonner le pouvoir une
première fois après un coup d'État
militaire puis réinstaller grâce à
l'intervention des États-Unis laisse le
pays dans un état de corruption et de
misère il aura mise en place en quelques
années un véritable système de
répression musclé
jérô quel long chemin parcouru par le
père Aristide depuis qu'il partit en
guerre à la fin des années 80 contre la
répression et les privilèges en Haïti
qu'elle semble lointaine cette époque
après la chute de la dictature du
dernier des Duvaliers Bébé Doc réfugié
avec sa femme sur la Côte d'Azur le père
des bidonville chantait la paix et
l'amour déjà pourtant jeanbertrand
Aristide a une double personnalité
il se lance entique pour défendre les
misux crée le mouvementavalace
l'avalanche et en décembre 90 il est élu
président avec 67 % des voix mais
quelques mois plus tard quand il se sent
menacé il oublie sa charité chrétienne
et encourage la foule de ses partisans à
faire subir à ses ennemis le supplice du
pneu
[Musique]
enflamméie respirer cela n'empêche pas
le coup d'État militaire fin septembre
91 le chef d'état-major Raoul sedras
prend le pouvoir Aristide part en exil
suivent 3 années d'une répression
sanglante des milliers de réfugiés
interceptés par les gardes decôte
américains sont parqués dans la base de
Guantanamo à Cuba Bill Clinton décide de
remettre aristi danscell en octobre 94
le président déchu revient dans les bag
de
20000 novembre 2000 il est réélu à la
tête du pays mais depuis renouant avec
la dictature des années 80 il s'était
maintenu au pouvoir grâce à des milices
armées fin 2003 l'opposition qui
regroupe beaucoup des anciens partisans
d'arestide descend dans la rue pour
réclamer sa
démission en janvier dernier pourtant
lors des célébrations du bicentenaire
d'Haïti le président espère encore
arriver jusqu'au terme de son mandat de
ans mais c'est sans compter sur la
rébellion armée qui va le pousser au
départ au Maroc depuis 24 he maintenant
le Roi Mohamed 6 s'est rendu sur les
ruines d'Alo sea le souverain annoncé
que tous les orphelins seraient pupill
de la nation l'ét les prenant en charge
aujourd'hui le Roi Mohamed 6 s'est rendu
dans une petite ville particulièrement
frappée par le tremblement de terre à
imsuren le roi qui malgré le désarroi et
la colère des sinistrés des premiers
jours faute de secours a été
acclamé en France une bonne nouvelle
pour les chauffeurs de poids lourd
bloqués depuis vendredi à la frontière
avec l'Espagne depuis la fin de journée
ils ont l'autorisation de reprendre la
route au total aujourd'hui plus de 5000
camions étent bloqué dans le sud-ouest
de la France d'interminables fils de
poids lourd à l'arrêt certains étant
répartis sur des zones de stockage où s
organiser tant bien que mal le
ravitaillement près de 48 heures de
galère reportage David bazier Philippe
jimay
18h30 le premier camion bloqué franchit
enfin le pH de Biriatou direction
l'Espagne une heure auparavant côté
espagnol le gouvernement autonome basque
annoncé à la surprise des autorités
françaises ouvrir à nouveau une
frontière que tout le monde pensait
fermer jusqu'à demain nons ass ave les
services de la Croix Rouge un
ravitaillement au passage des camions de
façon à réguler le flux l'autorisation
de repartir va être progressive
département par département afin de
gérer au mieux le départ de milliers de
routiers impatients à benessmine dans le
plus gros des bouchons on pouvait
croiser des enfants de camionneur et des
chauffeurs qui n'avaient plus beaucoup
de réserves de
nourriture lentement ce soir la 63 se
désengorge les Autoroutes du Sud de la
France font un geste ouis c'est gratté
dans ce sens ou rien qu'entre l'Espagne
et Bordeaux il y aurait plus de 8000
poid lourds à faire passer il faudra
sans doute du temps bien plus que la
nuit qui vient de la frontière espagnole
jusqu'à Poitier les camions ont donc
trouvé au refuge où ils ont pu l'exemple
au Parc des Expositions du lac dans la
Barlie de Bordeaux qui a été ouvert pour
l'occasion quelques 400 camions si'y
sont garé à l'arrêt sur différentes
aires de stationnement de la Gironde de
très nombreux poids lourds ont été
bloqué un réseau saturé au niveau des
aires de repos préciseent les gendarmes
à Poitier maintenant sur le parking du
Futuroscope près 300 camions élu
domicile dans l'ensemble du département
700 camions sont répartis sur les
différents sites la circulation devrait
reprendre à 22h en Bretagne maintenant
les chutes de neige de ces derniers
jours ont affecté les lignes à haute
tension EDF fait son possible mais
toujours 5000 familles privées
d'électricité un travail de fourmis
puisque la plupart des maisons privées
de courant sont dans des zones isolées
Jacques Devau Fabien de Loris corvé de
bois pour Simone et André depuis 3 jours
la cheminée est leur unique appareil de
chauffage dans le hameau du
les lignes électriques sont à terre
elles n'ont pas supporté le poids de la
neige les
congélateurs la lumière le chauffage
chauffage ça la télé c'est secondaire on
nait pas autre fois on peut s'en passer
ça heureusement pour le Bignot EDF peut
enfin s'occuper du réseau local les 80
habitants vont retrouver l'électricité
aujourd'hui à quelques kilomètres de là
des agents interviennent sur une autre
ligne mauvaise surprise il a cassé
il va falloir composer avec ce poteau
cassé une perte de temps qui s'ajoute à
la difficulté d'accéder au lieu
d'intervention là la plupart des des
champs sont cultivés en dessous donc bah
les les engins rentrent pas quoi c'est
trop mou quoi ça un peu gelé en surface
mais en dessous c'est c'est très mou
donc on va rentrer mais on va s'enfoncer
rapidement donc bah obligé de faireier
depuis vendredi 300 personnes
travaillent sur le secteur de pleu
Hermel des renforts indispensables pour
répondre à l'ampleur des dégâts sur une
année on a à peu près 90 à 100 incidents
et là sur les 3 jours c'était 65
incidents HTR sur ple Hermel vendredi
45000 clients étaient privés
d'électricité ce soir ils seront moins
de
1500 en Espagne enfin le mauvais temps
s'est installé pour le 3e jour de suite
neuf régions sont toujours en état
d'alerte la neige accompagnée de vent
violent a perturbé très fortement la
circulation notamment dans le nord du
pays d'autres pays d'Europe comme l'
Italie sont également touchés par le
mauvais temps il neige aux États-Unis un
cargot battant pavillon singapourien a
subi une très forte explosion le
pétrolier a coulé au large des côtes de
Virginie trois morts 18 disparus selon
un dernier bilan les hélicoptères
appuyés en mer par des vedettes ont
permis de sauver une partie des membres
de
l'équipage c'est demain que s'ouvre en
Belgique le procès de Marc du trou tous
les yeux sont braqués sur la petite
ville d'Arlon où se dérouleront les
audiences dans un palais de justice bien
trop exigu pour accueillir l'ensemble de
la presse qui couvrira l'événement
Caroline Gautier Jean-Marc nounou Harlon
prise d'assaut par les médias 2
télévisions radio journaux ont installé
leur quartier autour du palais de
justice des médias belges bien sûr des
journalistes de toute l'Europe et puis
quelques russes ou japonais un dimanche
très inhabituel pour cette petite ville
belge certes l'affaire du trou a eu un
retentissement international mais cette
déferlante médiatique effraie un peu
c'est jamais qu'une petite ville et je
crois que le procès et les moyens
déployés sont démesurés par rapport à la
ville que représente Arlon quoi et
pourtant dès ce soir le procès du trou
concentre tous les regards émission
spéciale en direct sur les chaînes de
télévision belge avec notamment la
participation de Martine van Prat et
Xavier manier deux des défenseurs de
marque du
trou en cette fin de journée le maire
d'Arlon tente une inspection discrète
des installations mais lui aussi est
assailli
l'élu prévoit donc un réveil matinal en
ce jour J demain matin ces portes de la
prison d'Arlon s'ouvriront pour laisser
passer le cortège des inculpés au centre
un fourgon opaque est blindé à
l'intérieur marque du trou son ex-fme et
son complice présumé Michel le lièvre
500 m à parcourir sous très haute
surveillance une fois les accusés arrivé
le procès du trou s'ouvrira l'affaire du
trou a été maillée de nombreux iement
d'erreurs si coupabl qu'elles ont
provoqué un véritable séisme politique
en Belgique l'émotion y est toujours
très présente et surtout le manque de
confiance dans les institutions du pays
le rappel de ses ratés de ces faux pas
jusqu'à l'invraisemblable évasion de
Marc duutrou Dominique
Verda le traumatisme est trop grand
alors fait exceptionnel le roi Albert I
convoque une table ronde en présence des
familles des victimes échec de la
justice et faillite de l'État sont
dénoncé par l'opinion publique et le
jugement royal et lui aussi sans appel
de nombreuses erreurs ont été
commises et dans les contacts avec les
famille des
victimes il y a eu un manque
d'humanité l'affaire du trou est une
succession de dérapage de
dysfonctionnement et de faux pas tout
commence en 92 le 8 avril marque du trou
est remise en liberté condamné à 13 ans
de prison pour enlèvement et viol il a
purgé la moitié de sa peine Melkor
Watley le ministre de la Justice qui a
autorisé cette sortie est prise à
parti Julie Mélissa Anne et Fieux c'est
tout un pays qui porte le deuil de ces
qu martyr écurement honte suspici sont
les sentiments les plus courants nous
sommes un pays où il plus de politicien
au m Carr et regardez le comportement je
suis écuré monsieur j'estime que quand
on va arriver au-dessus qu'on va voir
que ce sont les grosses légumes là on va
arrêter tout je jure de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité retransmise à
la télévision la commission
parlementaire va mettre au grand jour
les lacunes de l'enquête une mésentente
évidente et désastreuse entre les
gendarmes et les magistrats des
perquisitions qui ont été menées à la
légère et des informations qui n'ont pas
circulé entre service il faut bien vous
imaginer monsieur que tout le monde peut
suivre ce que vous avez dit
maintenant et que ça peut
aggraver la crise dans laquelle nous
sommes après 16 mois de travaux les
parlementaires condamnent la police et
la justice mais aucune mise en cause
personnelle et aucune sanction ne
suivront démarche assurée déterminé le
juge Jean-Marc conrot est décidé à aller
jusqu'au bout de son instruction mais il
commet un faux pas le 21 septembre il a
partagé un plat de spaghetti avec les
parents des fillettes jug parti le
magistrat malgré un impressionnant
soutien populaire et dessaisi du dossier
le 14 octobre pour les parents c'est une
épreuve de TR
n c'est comme si on crachait sur leur
t c'est
pareil la justice est condamnée par tout
un peuple les Belges défendent leur
héros le juge conrot les pompiers
arrosent le palais de justice comme pour
le laver de tous ces maots les étudiants
descendent dans la rue les ouvriers se
mettent en
gr la justice elle est malade
est malade comme t les institutions
publiques et c'est le moment de faire un
nettoyage làdedans est jeune et c'est
pour notre avenir qu'on fait ça c'est
pas pour s'amuser pour rater l'école ou
n'importe quoi c'est pour notre avenir
on entend déjà dire que c'est le système
qui coupable alors nouson bien direre le
système en prison alors avril 98
l'impensable l'homme le plus surveillé
de Belgique s'évade du palais de justice
de ne château les Belges vivent de
nouvelles heures noir certes la cavale
de Durou ne dure que 3 He mais ce nouvel
impère est
dévastateur
c'est une nouvelle histoire belge
grotesque qui qui ridiculise notre pays
qui n'en demandait pas
temp cette course ridicule
franchement conséquence le départ
immédiat du gouvernement du ministre de
la justice et du ministre de
l'Intérieur en tant que gestionnaire du
système nous devions tirer la conclusion
de le
cheli-ci qu' est triste de constater
c'est qu'il a que de ministr finalement
remis leur démission mais c'est tout le
gouvernement qui devit sauter dernier
avatar la goutte d'eau Marc Durou
s'exprime dans une émission d'une
télévision flamande un journaliste a
réussi à s'introduire avec la complicité
d'un sénateur dans la cellule du
prisonnier du trou il défend la thèse du
résseau c'est une nouvelle claque pour
les institutions mais c'est aussi un
record
d'audience moi je reconnais que j'ai
gardé Julie chez moi donc je suis pas
innocent j'ai garder un focher moi je
suis pas innocent j'ai jamais dit que
j'étais innocent mais il faut que chacun
ait sa part de
responsabilité demain quatre accusés
seront dans le box mais le procès sera
aussi celui de la police et de la
justice et 8 ans plus tard la confiance
ne semble pas être revenu à l'heure
actuelle malgré les efforts qui sont
faits par le gouvernement 67 % des
Belges n'ont pas confiance dans leur
justice c'est quand même extrêmement
grave un monument improvisé au palais de
justice de Bruxelles à la mémoire des
victimes de Durou et des enfants
disparus symbole d'une Belgique
traumatisée en direct d'Arlon nous vous
retrouvons Dominique verdaillan 8 ans
après lesffet et sans aucun doute sur la
culpabilité de Marc duutrou que peut-on
attendre au fond de ce procès ah ben
écoutez beaucoup si on en croit le
nombre de médias de mémoire de
chroniqueurs judiciair on n jamais vu
une telle organisation médiatique
j'allais dire un show médiatique en tout
cas c'est plus que lors du procès du
président milozevic à là et beaucoup
aussi du cou côté de la défense
apparemment puisque aujourd'hui Marc
duutrou a fait savoir qu'il allait
pendant son procès charger l'un de ses
coaccusés Michel niou celui qui incarne
justement la thèse du réseau pas
grand-chose en revanche du côté des
principaux intéressés à savoir les
parents des victimes elles seront très
peu ils seront très peu nombreux demain
au Palais de Justice d'Arlon certains
d'entre eux ont dit qu'ils ne
participeraient pas à ce qu'ils
appellent une mascarade à un cirque
alors les attentes des familles mais
aussi de l'opinion publique c'est une
sorte de plaider coupable de méaculpat
des enquêteurs des magistrats des juges
d'instruction devant cette somme de
dérapage la cour elle est saisie
simplement de faits criminels de la
l'éventuelle culpabilité de quatre
personnes on juge marque duutrou pas les
institutions à leur question la justice
belge d'aujourd'hui va-t-elle faire
oublier la justice belge d'hier nous
verrons merci Dominique ver d'illeur
nous vous retrouvons bien sûr demain la
lutte contre l'insécurité routière avec
avec dès demain lundi l'apparition d'un
permis de conduire à destination des
jeunes conducteurs qui les mettra à
l'épreuve pendant une période de 3 ans
le permis n'est plus acquis à vie cette
mesure est nécessaire mais pas
suffisante répondent certaines
associations leurendi une carcasse
démentibulé et cinq jeunes âgés de 16 à
20 ans qui trouvent la mort c'était en
octobre un accident dû à un abus
d'alcool pour limiter ce genre de drame
le gouvernement met en place à partir de
demain un nouveau permis six points
seulement pour un conducteur novice lui
dit vous aurez les six autres points
donc la totalité du capital à l'issue
d'un délai de 3 ans si et seulement si
vous ne commettez aucune infraction
sinon le conducteur repart pour une
nouvelle période probatoire de 3 ans et
s'il perd les 6 points le permis est
alors invalidé avec interdiction de le
repasser pendant 6 mois enfin certaines
infractions graves entraîneront la perte
automatique du permis de conduire la
conduite avec une alcool émie de plus de
0,5 g ou après une consommation de stup
défiant mais aussi le délit de fite ou
une récidive de grand excès de vitesse
des mesures plutôt bien acceptées que
certains voudraient voir complétter par
des aides
financières cette bourse serait pour des
jeunes qui n'ont pas les moyens
financiers de dépasser les 20 heur de
conduite c'est les forfaits qu'on offre
en auto-école donc ces jeunes grâce à
cette bourse pourraient prendre des
heures supplémentaires dont ils ont
besoin pour leur sécurité pour celle des
autres des conducteurs qui seraient donc
mieux formés qui risqueraient moins de
rater le permis ou de le perdre et qui
n'irait donc pas rejoindre les 700000
personnes estimées qui conduisent en
France sans le permis accident de
voiture à un passage à niveau pourtant
passage à niveau gardé dans le Pas de
calis une voiture est entrée en
collision avec un TER les deux passagers
du véhicule ont été grièvement blessé
une enquête a été ouverte à 3 semaines
des régionales l'UDF tenait aujourd'hui
sa convention à tour avec sur place les
têtes de liste régional photo de famille
autour de François Baayou qui considère
que son parti ne peut accepter que le
pays je cite glisse vers laabîe l'UDF
joue la carte du changement et la NUG
Edmar banis VI 100 ans long VI au
président s fin des candidats qui se
voient déjà président de Région vive le
présidentou à 3 semaines du premier tour
des élections l'optimisme est de rigueur
à
l'UDF en rencerré autour de François
baayerou les 16 têtes de liste UDF
autonome au régional leur objectif
capter les voix des déçus de droite
comme de gauche empêcher qu'elle n'aille
vers les
extrêmes nos forces sont ceux qu'elles
sont mais nous ne pouvons pas accepter
que notre pays glisse
ainsi de déception en déception vers
l'abîme nous
décidons de proposer qu'il se redresse
nous décidons de proposer un changement
des centristes de plus en plus critiques
à l'égard de leurs partenair la
toutepuissante UMP et ce malgré la mise
en garde du seul ministre UDF du
gouvernement c'est vrai que le premier
tour est difficile et que le premier
tour est bien engagé pour l'UDF et pour
la famille centriste mais nous avons le
devoir de penser également au deuxème
tour et donc quelque part nous avons les
uns et les autres aussi à savoir saluer
le travail qu' fait ou l'UDF ne préside
aujourd'hui qu'une seule région ronalp
etesère en gagner au moins deux autres
la kit et l'île-defance et ainsi changer
le rapport de force à droite Lionel
juspin était à lance hier soir pour
assister à un match de football on
retiendra les quelques commentaires
politique de l'ancien Premier ministre
je vous propose de l'écouter les
Français ont l'occasion de de s'exprimer
depuis
2002 bon ils ont vu ce qui s'est passé
en 2 ans quelle est la politique
conduite il y aura pas d'autres
élections il y aura les européennes
bientôt mais sinon il y aura pas
d'autres élections avant 2007 donc s'ils
ont envie de faire passer un
message c'est maintenant quoi gros plan
sur la Bretagne une région vous le savez
qui est traditionnellement à droite mais
les jeux ne sont pas faits un des thèmes
porteurs repris par la plupart des
candidats le désenclavement Émilie lanan
Patrick
VO la Bretagne en quelques mots pour la
droite c'est une Bretagne
dynamique
solidaire accessible hein et attractive
vu par la gauche cela donne plus
solidaire à mon avis plus
gay plus dynamique plus plus festif
parce que plein
d'espoir pas facile de s'y retrouver et
le duel s'annonce serré pourtant si l'on
y regarde de plus près les différences
sont bel et bien là fait du bien c'est
rachal
ça réchauffe en breton le duc de Ran ne
fait pas de manière président um sortant
il veut avant tout désenclaver la
Bretagne et se félicite d'y avoir
facilité l'accès à Internet tout le
territoire est aujourd'hui relié au
réseau à Ha débit et c'est une
performance que peu de régions peu de
régions peuvent se
prévaloir à gauche Jean ledant ancien
prof d'histoire insiste sur le social et
le mieux vivre en
bretagneésident droite n'ide pas le
logement social dans les villes elle
n'aide le logement social que dans les
campagnes c'est une volonté politique
qui manque et les principales victimes
sont les jeunes mais certains entendent
compliquer le jeu comme Bruno Joncour à
droite de l'image candidat UDF sa
présence énerve à l'UMP et inquiète à
gauche l'UDF est un partenaire qui sur
le plan social peut en quelque sorte
gêner ce qui à gauche considère souvent
qu'ils ont l'exclusivité dans ce domaine
traditionnellement bas en Bretagne le
Front national pourrait lui aussi
réserver des surprises et accéder au
second tour le salon de l'agriculture
avec d'actualité la crise du vin
l'occasion pour les viticulteurs de
mobiliser en proposant de sortir de la
loi et vin les boissons agricoles
Laurence de cher Frédéric fort les
consommateurs sont là mais la
consommation n'y est plus les
dégustations de vin ne manquent pas le
salon de l'agriculture mais les ventes
continuent de diminuer en France alors
quand on attaque leur publicité pour les
viticulteurs la coupe est pleine les
vigrons sont en colère parce que ils ont
de plus en plus ils ont leurs
difficultés conjoncturell économique
comme tous les secteurs mais se lever le
matin en disant on va encore me prendre
pour un tueur ou me prendre pour un
dealer ça les gens ils peuvent plus de
toutes les régions on peut plus le
supporter après la campagne de pub pour
les vins de Bourgogne c'est celle des
Bordeaux qui est mise en cause pour
manquement à la et vin les
manifestations se sont multipliées cette
semaine les vignerons réclament une
exception pour le vin on peut plus boire
on peut plus déguster on peut plus la
peur du gendarme il faut il faut que
l'on puisse nous promotionner pour faire
connaître à toutes ces nouvelles
générations que le vin c'est pas de
l'alcool c'est c'est la géographie
française c'est les terroirs une
exception qui pourrait prendre la forme
d'un amendement à la loivin les
consommateurs sont partagés consommateur
est adulte je crois que la publicité la
vie tous les jours pour n'importe quel
produit et en est à même de de faire la
part des choses je vois pas d'alcool
fort par exemple j'apprécie pas ça
j'aime beaucoup le vin mais un excès des
deux peut amener les mêmes conséquences
dramatiques spécialement sur la route
les viticulteurs et le ministre de
l'Agriculture Hervé guemard on
rendez-vous mercredi prochain loin des
festivités du salon pour tenter de
trouver un terrain
d'entente ça ne vous aura pas échappé
nous sommes le 29 février une drôle de
date anniversaire pour tous ceux qui qui
sont nés ce jour-là illustration
Frédéric Monteille et Olivier
Robert joyeux
anniversaire 40 bougies sur le gâteau un
refrain bien connu et pourtant rien
d'évident pour Laurent scandel né le
février 1964 elle ne peut vraiment
souffler ses bougies qu'une fois tous
les 4 ans quand j'ai annoncé que j'étais
né à 29 février il y en a qui me
disaient mais non ça existe pas le 29
février ou d'autres me disaient mais
alors mais alors tu es plus jeune que
nous tu le fais tous les 4 ans donc tu
prends un an tous les 4 ans ou
alors ou alors il me demandait quand
est-ce que je le fêtais si je le fêtais
avant après c'était plus une histoire de
on va dire technique et oui une année
bissextile c'est toujours un peu
technique et quand on feuillette le
calendrier on s'aperçoit en remontant le
temps que c'est Jules César lui-même qui
a réformé le premier tous les jours de
l'année à l'époque de César les saisons
étaient décalées de 90 jours avec le
calendrier donc en 46 avant Jésus-Christ
césar décide de réformer le calendrier
il bouleverse tout et il crée le
calendrier quasiment tel qu'on le
connaît à l'heure actuelle mais les
hommes n'ont jamais réussi à se caler
parfaitement sur la course du soleil
aujourd'hui une année compte donc 365
jours 5h 48 minutes et 46 secondes
résultat une fois tous les 4 ans on
déborde ça nouveau une journée de
rattrapage le 29 et pour Laurence enfin
un anniversaire en temps
réel en marche de toutes les grandes
compétition de ski professionnel il
existe un championnat de France des
familles chacun peut y participer les
qualifications ont lieu actuellement
dans de nombreuses station de ski à
l'Alpe du did Guillot thierier le papa
descend allez
papa il arrive jusqu'en bas son arrivée
déclenche le départ de la maman allez
maman quand elle arrive en bas c'est le
départ de l'enfant et c'est l'enfant qui
détermine qu est la
famille affrontement sportif et surtout
familial pour une vingtaine de familles
françaises ici on ne retrouve que des
amateurs amoureux de ski et qui viennent
en équipe chercher une
victoire on aime la montagne on est va
en famille on ski en famille on se
retrouve sur le stade en famille donc s'
une compétition en famille on la
fait dosard top départ chronomètre juge
arbitre tout y est presque comme des
professionnels ces familles sont là en
vacances à l'Alpe du et les voici partis
à TR enalom parallèle afin de se mesurer
aux autes mon fils en fait mon mari en
fait mais pas moi et c'est angoissant ça
se voit pas je tremble
encore la plupart des familles rêvent de
gagner mais on est surtout là par jeu
heureux de se retrouver ensemble ski au
pied pendant quelques instants dans la
peau d'un
champion ça fait une semaine qui nous
tanne pour s'inscrire donc ça fait 30
ans qu'on n pas fait de slalom on s'est
remis
aujourd'huiinr à la flèche à midi pour
s'entraîner et juste pour faire plaisir
au fils
ce weekend trois familles ont été
sélectionnées pour la grande finale qui
aura lieu le weekend prochain en
Morienne dans la station du
corder les Victoires de la musique avec
le succès de la nouvelle génération
Micke
3D Carla brun K sont au palmarès Olivier
her mais il m'ont don le j'en reviens
pas incrédule Carla j'en reviens pas
on rend compte pense qu'on un on est là
on ils ont à peine 25 ans et tr
victoires plein les main le triomp de la
jeune
[Musique]
génération artiste de l'année je me
considère un pe commeeçon et j'ai la
notion des
aînés
respect des des aînés quoi le respect
des
aînés le combat des idées Micke 3D 3
récompenses dire et un souhait que tous
les intermittents donc 90 % sont des
gens de la France d'en bas soi enfin
pris en compte et puis que dans ce pays
on s'occupe enfin enfin des gens de la
france d' bas voilà merci s sérino lui
s'adresse au gouvernement on vous
propose un autre
protocole lisez-le quoi s'il vous plaît
cette contreproposition je la faisais
étudier
d'Illes l'ÉE est actuellement cours elle
sera rendue en début de semaine voil
tenue de soirée pour la poupée de son
Émilie Simon symbole de la Nouvelle
Vague c'est Audel de de ce que j'avais
imaginé je suis F d'appartenir au
paysage musical français je retourner à
la réalité mais ce soir je vais avoir le
melon pendant quelques heures je n'étais
pas de Cell à qui l' fait la cour moi
j'étais de Cell qui sont déjà
et puis il eu Pascal Obispo des années
qu'il attendait ce trophée lui le plus
jeune de la génération
précédente
merci aux États-Unis la Fête du Cinéma
la cérémonie des Oscars dans quelques
heures à Hollywood le rendez-vous de
toutes les stars qui défineront sur le
tapis rouge donner grand favori le
seigneur des anneaux avec 11 nominations
parmi les vedettes présentes Tom HKS
Sting ou encore René Z
sorti mercredi prochain sur les écrans
de feu rouge avec pour la première fois
réunie à l'écran Carole Bouquet et
Jean-Pierre Daroussin un trillur
Français adapté d'un roman de simn
transposé des États-Unis des années 50 à
la France d'aujourd'hui Marie joouan et
Marine
mincant alors qu'élè et Antoine vont
chercher leurs enfants en vacances dans
le sud Antoine exaspéré par les
embouteillages décide de quitter
l'autoroute furieuse moi bah oui toi
évidemment de qui veux-tu que je parle
que tu es furieuse par que j'ai eu
l'audace de pas suivre cette petite
flèche et qu'on va faire un détour de
quelques kilomètres un chemin de
traverse qui va révéler au propre comme
au figuré la crise profonde
existentielle que vit Antoine le mari
quelqu'un qui cherche à se faire aimer
qui cherche à reséduire qui cherche des
qui qui veut retrouver sa dignité et
l'estime de lui-même là où il s'enfonce
il avait pas prévu évidemment tout ce
qu' allait lui arriver descend cette
voiture je continue toute seule Hélène
part seule dans la nuit à la radio on
apprend qu'un dangereux criminal s'est
évadé le film tourne au polar noir la
descente aux enfers commence Mons dun
vous m'entendez c'est un très beau film
sur la difficulté de vivre ensemble sur
l'attirance qu'on a homme ou femme pour
le désastre pour le chaos pour l'enfer
pourquoi est-on autestructeur pourquoi
tout d'un coup on abîme quelque chose
qu'on
aime une histoire adapté d'un roman de
Simenon avec la route pour décor et
l'habitacle de la voiture pour abriter
le HL joué par un couple d'acteurs inéd
au cinéma l'association Carole Bou
Jean-Pierre Daroussin il fallait y
penser cédri a relevé le défi à l'écran
cela devient une évidence c'est toujours
un peu dérisoire de voir des gens
ensemble quand on connaî par où ils sont
passés on conna leur histoire quand vous
regardez une photo de vos grands-parents
sont en train de sourire à l'objectif et
que si vous saviez leur vie peut-être
que vous la verriiez autrement alors si
vous vous trouvez pris dans les
embouteillages ne vous fiez pas aux
apparences observez bien autour de vous
et imaginez le pire ainsi se termine ce
journal tout de suite la météo Laurent
Resco 20h50 Jackie Brown de Quentin
Tarantino 1hure le dernier journal Le
Journal de la nuit avec jean- Claude
Renaud demain 7h40 dans les cas de
vérité Françoise Laborde reçoit Michel
vosel 13h Daniel Bilalian 20h Carole
Gessler et puis demain soir la 100e de
mauxs croisé d'Arlet chabo deux thèmes
le procès du trou comment un fait divert
devient une affaire d'état et puis la
pollution et les pesticides quel risque
pour notre santé débat avec Hervé
guemard Philippe Devillet et Jean Michel
Le méteyer le président de la FNSEA
quant à moi je vous remercie de votre
attention excellente fin de soirée sur
France
[Musique]